PRESIDENT BIDEN FINALLY BANNING
RUSSIAN OIL AS PUTIN'S WARM
MACHINE RAMPS UP ATTACKS ON
UKRAINIAN CIVILIANS.
UNDER BIPARTISAN PRESSURE BIDEN
ANNOUNCING A STOP TO IMPORTED
RUSSIAN ENERGY.
BUT INSTEAD OF PROMISING TO
PRODUCE MORE OIL HERE AT HOME,
THE PRESIDENT POINTED THE FINGER
AT EVERYBODY ELSE AND DOUBLED
DOWN ON GOING GREEN.
>> I'M GOING TO DO EVERYTHING I
CAN TO MINIMIZE PUTIN'S PRICE
HIKE AT HOME.
IT'S SIMPLY NOT TRUE MY
ADMINISTRATIONS OR POLICIES ARE
HOLDING BACK DOMESTIC ENERGY
PRODUCTION.
THE OIL AND GAS INDUSTRY HAS
MILLIONS OF ACRES LEASED AND
9,000 PERMITS TO DRILL, THEY
COULD BE DRILLING LAST WEEK,
LAST YEAR.
LOOSENING REGULATIONS WON'T, LET
ME SAY, WILL NOT, LOWER ENERGY
PRICES FOR FAMILIES BUT
TRANSFORMING OUR ECONOMY TO RUN
ON ELECTRIC VEHICLES POWERED BY
CLEAN ENERGY WITH TAX CREDITS TO
HELP FAMILIES WINTERIZE THEIR
HOMES AND USE LESS ENERGY, THAT
WILL HELP.
>> Jesse: WHILE PRESIDENT BIDEN
FOCUSES ON THAT, AMERICANS ARE
GETTING CRUSHED BY SURGING COST
PRICES.
THE COST HITTING AN ALL TIME
HIGH OF $4.17 WITH NO SIGNS OF
SLOWING DOWN.
AND VP KAMALA HARRIS NOT DOING
MUCH BETTER.
CHECK OUT THESE TONE DEAF
COMMENTS ALL AMERICAN.
>> IMAGINE ALL THE HEAVY DUTY
VEHICLES THAT KEEP OUR SUPPLY
LINES STRONG AND ALLOW OUR
ECONOMY TO GROW.
IMAGINE THAT THEY PRODUCED ZERO
EMISSION.
WELL, YOU ALL IMAGINED IT.
THAT'S WHY WE'RE HERE TODAY.
WE ARE ALSO ANNOUNCING FUNDING
FOR, YES, ONE OF MY FAVORITE
TOPICS, ELECTRIC SCHOOL BUSES.
>> Jesse: LIKE SHE'S DOING A
READING AT KINDERGARTEN.
GET TO HER IN A SECOND.
BUT I HERD SOME GRUPP BLINGS
FROM YOU WHEN BIDEN WAS BLAMING
ENERGY COMPANIES FOR HIGH
PRICES.
>> THIS IS THE THING THAT DRIVES
ME CRAZY.
REMEMBER WHEN THE BIDEN WHITE
HOUSE, I REMEMBER THE DAY FOX
NEWS SUNDAY, AND A SENIOR
ADVISOR CAME ON AND SAID IT WAS
ACTUALLY REPUBLICANS WHO WANTED
TO DEFUND THE POLICE.
AND I SAID ARE THEY SAYING THAT
WITH A STRAIGHT FACE AND TRY TO
GET AWAY WITH THAT?
AND THEN THEY DID FOR A COUPLE
WEEKS AND THEN DROPPED IT
BECAUSE IT'S NOT TRUE.
I FEEL THE SAME WAY ABOUT THIS
ENERGY AS WELL.
WE WERE ALREADY SEEING REALLY
HIGH ENERGY PRICES BEFORE
RUSSIAN INVADED UKRAINE, LET'S
START THERE AND IF YOU LOOK OVER
THE PAST, YOU CAN FIND THE
QUOTES, WE PLAYED ONE THIS
MORNING OF THE SECRETARY OF
ENERGY LAUGHING ABOUT HIGH GAS
PRICES ON NOVEMBER 3RD SAYING
WOW, IF I HAD A MAGIC WAND I
WOULD LOVE TO DO THAT.
OVER AND OVER AGAIN YOU CAN FIND
ADMINISTRATION OFFICIALS SAYING
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO GO
THROUGH PAIN IN ORDER FOR US TO
DO WHAT HAS TO BE DONE BECAUSE
THE WORLD'S GOING TO END IN TEN
YEARS BECAUSE OF CLIMATE CHANGE
AND THEY BASICALLY SAID THE
HIGHER PRICES ARE WHAT YOU WERE
GOING TO HAVE TO PAY.
THE WHOLE POINT ABOUT THE
LEASES, WHAT BOTHERS ME --
PERMISSION TO MAKE AN ANALOGY.
>> Jesse: GRANTED.
>> Dana: IMAGINE YOU GET A NEW
CAR, YOU FINANCE A CAR, YOU GO
THROUGH ALL THE PAPERWORK,
YOU'RE SO EXCITED.
BUT THEY WON'T GIVE YOU THE
KEYS.
THAT'S WHAT'S HAPPENING.
SO THEY'RE SAYING WHAT DO YOU
MEAN?
YOU CAN DRILL TOMORROW.
BUT I DON'T HAVE THE KEYS TO DO
THAT.
>> Jesse: YOU HAVE THE LEASE BUT
YOU DON'T HAVE THE PERMIT.
>> Dana: EXACTLY RIGHT.
THE OTHER THING IS THEY HAVE
TRIED TO GET SO MUCH INK FROM A
SYMPATHETIC MEDIA ABOUT HOW
GREAT THEY'VE BEEN ABOUT TRYING
TO GET AMERICA OFF FOSSIL FUEL
AND THEY'RE OUTSOARINGSING ALL
OF THEIR CARBON EMISSIONS TO
SAUDI, VENEZUELA, RUSSIAN, ET
CETERA.
FINAL THING I'D LIKE TO SAY IS
WHEN KAMALA HARRIS SAYS GO BUY A
$50,000 ELECTRIC VEHICLE.
ON WHAT PLANET ARE THEY LIVING
ON?
IT'S LIKE SHE SAID THAT NOBODY
SAW THE OMICRON VARIANT COMING.
SO WHY WEREN'T THEY PLANNING ON
ANY OF THESE RUSSIAN SANCTIONS
ON OIL AND GAS BEFORE.
WHY DO THEY HAVE TO WAIT FOR
KICKING AND SCREAMING AND
WAITING FOR 76 OF AMERICA TO SAY
WE'RE WILLING TO PAY HIGHER
PRICES.
WHY DO THEY HAVE TO WAIT FOR
THEIR POLL NUMBERS TO SAY THIS
IS WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN.
WHY DID THEY HAVE TO WAIT FOR
NANCY PELOSI TO SAY NO WE'RE
DOING THIS AND SHE WAS GOING
THROUGH WITHOUT THEM.
BAD DAY ON THE ENERGY FRONT
HOWEVER IT COULD LEAD TO
SOMETHING BETTER AND IF WE'RE
PUSHING ON THE DOOR AND ALLOWS
FOR MORE EXPLORATION IN AMERICA
IT'S GOOD.
>> Jesse: YOU HAVE TO PUSH HARD
ON THESE GUYS.
WE WERE PUSHING FOR THE RUSSIAN
IMPORT BAN AND THEY CAVED.
MAYBE THERE'S A CHANCE IF THE
PRESSURE BUILDS.
>> Greg: WHAT, 8% OF OUR
IMPORTS?
THAT COULD EASILY BE ABSORBED BY
DRILLING MORE OR EVEN LIKE
HITTING CANADA UP FOR MORE.
BUT I LIKE HOW JOE IS FRAMING
THIS.
THIS IS A HARDSHIP THAT WE MUST
ACCEPT.
HE SAID DEFENDING FREEDOM COMES
AT A COST.
AND THAT IS NOT TRUE.
THAT IS NOT -- IT'S THE
ENVIRONMENTAL CLAP TRAP THAT
COMES AT A COST.
THIS IS NOT ABOUT FREEDOM.
THERE WOULD BE NO COST IF WE
DIDN'T DEMONIZE DRILLING AND
SHUT DOWN LINES AND DEMONIZE
FUEL.
IT'S NOT ABOUT BEENING WHY IT'S
ABOUT EXPOSING THE
DESTRUCTIVENESS OF THE GREEN
IDEOLOGY WHICH IS PART OF A
LARGER IDEOLOGY OF PUNISHMENT,
RIGHT?
RICH COUNTRIES CAN HANDLE THIS,
JUST PAY MORE GAS.
IT'S THE POOR COUNTRIES THAT ARE
GOING TO SUFFER AND IT'S GOING
TO BE POOR PEOPLE IN THE UNITED
STATES, RIGHT?
SO YOU HAVE TWITTER CELEBRITIES
LIKE GEORGE TAKAI SAYING THEY
SHOULD PAY MORE TO SUPPORT
UKRAINE BUT THEY'RE NOT TRUCKERS
OR SALES MEN OR UBER DRIVERS.
THIS IS THE SAME MENTALITY THAT
WE FOUND WITH SHUTDOWNS, RIGHT?
EVERYBODY COULD HANDLE A
SHUTDOWN IF THEY WERE IN THE
MEDIA BECAUSE WE ALL DID OUR
SHOWS FROM OUR LIVING ROOMS.
SAME PEOPLE THAT TELL US TO LIVE
WITH IT CAN LIVE WITH ANYTHING.
SO THAT'S EITHER CLIMATE CHANGE,
COVID, INFLATION.
AND ONCE YOU SEE THAT YOU CAN'T
UNSEE IT.
THERE'S AN IDEOLOGY OF
PUNISHMENT AND IT'S THAT YOU CAN
HANDLE THE PUNISHMENT, THEY'RE
ABOVE IT.
>> Jesse: I SAW SOME MEDIA
TODAY, JUDGE JEANINE, AND THEY
WEREN'T CLAMORING FOR BIDEN TO
PASS OUT MORE PERMITS AND
LEASES.
THEY WERE TELLING AMERICANS YOU
JUST HAVE TO DRIVE SLOWER, YOU
KNOW, DON'T ACCELERATE TOO FAST.
THAT'S HOW YOU SAVE.
PUT ON THE SWEATER, RIGHT?
>> Judge Jeanine: YEAH, WELL,
YOU KNOW, THEY ACTUALLY REFERRED
TO IT AS PUTIN'S PRICE HIKE.
YOU KNOW, LET'S MAKE THE NEW
ENERGY PUTIN AS IF WE DIDN'T
HATE THE GUY ENOUGH ALREADY.
LOOK, BIDEN STARTED THE WAR ON
ENERGY LONG BEFORE PUTIN DECIDED
TO INVADE UKRAINE AND THE
TROUBLE WITH THIS IS, FOR ANYONE
TO BELIEVE THAT THIS IS REALLY
ABOUT RUSSIAN AND THE UKRAINE,
THAT IS TO ACTUALLY IGNORE THE
FACT THAT, FOR YEARS, THERE'S
THIS GREEN LEFT ENERGY
CONSTITUENCY TRYING TO GET US
INTO ELECTRIC CARS.
ONE % OF AMERICANS HAVE ELECTRIC
CARES.
I DON'T CARE HOW MUCH KAMALA
WANTS TO GO UP THERE AND LAUGH
AND GIGGLE AND SAY IMAGINE.
I FEEL LIKE I'M IN THE MIDDLE OF
A JOHN LENNON SONG.
I'M NOT GOING TO DRIVE AN
ELECTRIC CAR RIGHT AWAY AND
WE'VE GOT TO GET OIL AND GAS
FROM SOMEWHERE.
WE CAN DO IT IN THE UNITED
STATES, WE ALREADY KNOW THAT.
THIS IS WHAT I THIS THINK IS
MOST INSULTING TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
IF YOU REALLY THINK THE PEOPLE
THAT PRODUCE OIL ARE NOT
CHOMPING AT THE BIT SAYING HOLY
MOLY IT'S 130 BUCKS A BARREL,
I'VE GOT TO GET MYSELF INTO THIS
BUSINESS, I WANT TO MAKE SOME
MONEY.
THEY CAN'T EVEN GET A PERMIT TO
MAKE A ROAD TO GET TO THE SITE
WHERE THE LEASE TAKES THEM LET
ALONE DECIDE WHETHER OR NOT
THERE'S OIL OR GAS, WHETHER OR
NOT THEY CAN DRILL.
I MEAN, EVERYTHING THEY'RE DOING
IS ANTI AMERICAN.
>> Jesse: YOU KNOW THE PEOPLE
THAT MOST GERALDO IF YOU'RE
MAKING 50, 60 GRAND A YEAR.
>> YOU TALKING ABOUT RICH
PEOPLE?
OIL PEOPLE?
>> Jesse: TALKINGING ABOUT
REGULAR AMERICANS.
>> I DO KNOW REGULAR AMERICANS.
>> Jesse: IF YOU'RE MAKING THAT
MUCH MONEY AND SPENDING A
HUNDRED DOLLARS TO FILL UP YOUR
TRUCK, HOW LONG CAN YOU WAIT FOR
A WIND MULL.
>> MY FEAR JESSE IS THAT WE ARE
HE A BURYING THE LEAD.
THE LEAD IS NO MORE RUSSIAN
BLOOD OIL.
THAT'S THE LEAD.
SO RUSSIA HAS BEEN HIT.
NOW WITH THE SANCTION, THE ONLY
SANCTION THAT THEY TRULY FEAR
WAS A CUTOFF OF THEIR ONLY
PRODUCT.
RUSSIA, AFTER ALL IS A FIRST
WORLD ARM, THIRD WORLD COUNTRY
GAS STATION, THAT'S ALL IT IS.
IT PRODUCES OIL AND GAS.
SO WE'VE HURT THEM.
WE FINALLY HAVE HIT THEM WHERE
IT HURTS.
THEY ARE KILLING CIVILIANS AND
UNLEASHED THIS MASSIVE REFUGEE
CRISIS.
THEY HAVE DESTROYING THIS POOR
COUNTRY, UKRAINE, ON THEIR
BORDER.
I WANTED TO STICK IT TO THEM AND
I THINK THE PRESIDENT FINALLY
HAS.
EXXON, MOBILE AND CHEVRON, AS
YOU KNOW, TODAY ANNOUNCED THAT
THEY ARE INCREASING PRODUCTION
IN THE BASIN FOR EXACTLY THE
REASONS JUDGE JEANINE THAT YOU
SUGGEST, THEY WANT TO CASH IN.
BUT I ALSO THINK THAT WE HAVE TO
GO WITH CAUTION.
THESE OIL SPECULATEERS ARE THE
WOLVES OF WALL STREET.
THESE ARE THE PEOPLE THAT DROVE
THE PRICE OF A BARREL OF OIL
DOWN TO ZERO AT A CERTAIN POINT
BECAUSE OF SPECULATION.
>> Jesse: WASN'T THAT DURING THE
PANDEMIC?
>> THERE'S A LOT OF PROFIT
TEARING GOING ON IS MY POINT AND
I THINK IF YOU JUST SAY IT'S ALL
ABOUT BIDEN NOT DRILLING YOU'RE
MISSING SOME OF THE TRUTH.
>> Judge Jeanine: ARE YOU
SERIOUS?
>> I'M SERIOUS.
>> Jesse: SOMETIMES.
>> YOU MAY TAKE ME UNSERIOUS BUT
I'M SERIOUS.
>> Greg: GOOD NEWS IS McDONAL